hi I'm Emily Ekins and I'm the polling
director at Reason Foundation we
recently conducted a poll of 696
California voters including 508 likely
voters we asked him about the
presidential election California ballot
initiatives and municipal pension and
higher education reform Californians are
concerned about the trajectory of the
state of California in fact fifty-eight
percent think it's off on the wrong
track between 2000 and 2010 the
California State Legislature increase
spending per capita by forty two percent
what surprised me was that a majority of
Californians actually thought this
increased spending decreased their
quality of life and a majority favored
rolling back spending to 2000 levels
proposition 30 is a temporary tax
increase on higher income families as
well as a sales tax increase with the
intent of raising about six billion
dollars in additional revenue for
education including higher education the
results are too close to call slightly
more in favor about fifty percent plan
to vote yes on proposition 30 and about
46 plan to vote no so we followed up
with respondents asking them if
proposition 30 were to pass but it did
not raise enough revenue to close the
deficit what would they like the state
legislature to do next seventy-four
percent want the legislature to cut
spending to balance the budget
Californians are not just concerned with
the level of spending but also about
regulations that the California
government is passing in fact two-thirds
of them think that most of the laws and
regulations passed drive jobs out of the
state of California so these are just
some of the results from our poll to
learn more about what Californians think
about the California state economy
government employee reform outsourcing
trash collection and the political bias
of higher education professors go to
reason calm / poll
you